what's up everybody
Mary here with Mike my hearty hey you're
hyperventilating already yeah I have
pretty stressed out from the last
episode we are reading Knievel
we're playing the first Resident Evil
let's see where we're at
I just this isn't really indicative of
where we are got the shotgun I'm in the
safe zone I have a shotgun
oh I started burning bods which I can I
actually think is so beneficial
I should like start doing that more I've
used the sword key I think almost the
point where we don't need it anymore
which is fantastic and I got this bag of
chemicals that's new right
that's what's tough about this game
right you have to get a item you have no
idea what it does you have to weigh like
shreds put in a safe box for now or am I
gonna go like through six hallways and
then end up needing and have to come
back well I feel like if it's anything
like what happened before I'm already on
caution if I take one bite to the but
I'm gonna need a plant and I can't even
pick up a plant right now so I feel like
I'd rather put it in a safe box or one
of these items in a safe box
maybe my ink ribbons because they're
useless if you're not actually saving is
their safe box in this area go to your
map any typewriter item box any rooms
are safe any room that has a typewriter
will also have a box is that weird
no no just those ones specific like
right now you know so all I have to do
is go through this upper blue door to
the stairs well that's not the upper
blue door that's the lower blue door all
right
but remember yes so the very beginning
of the game the first zombie you saw
that killed Kenneth and then Barry
killed it yes if you remember that room
with the crows that you went through yes
it went up to remember you okay so
remember you got that oh it's telling
you got a shortcut recently so that'll
help you get back to the safe room
you're talking about back the way I came
with the e little dog so you could go
one of two ways right now you could
either go into the main hall and
upstairs so you're on the upper that
circular balcony where that zombie is in
the counting room or you can use the
shortcut with the dog
no no that's the east side you can use
that shortcut you got up near I'm gonna
I'll tell you just so you get a better
layout just so you understand the first
thing I'm still after all this and we've
been in a lot of places this place is so
[ __ ] confusing oh yeah it takes time
you like when you're done you'll have it
burned into your brain and there's like
a basement and there's a third floor we
haven't even started on but my second
floor knowledge all right so if we go
upstairs on the balcony do I get to the
2f you'll get to the safe room about the
same time a little faster but remember
okay so see these two red doors in the
hallway you have not tried those yet
with the sword key right all right well
I've just saved so I'm okay but we're
not mrs. if I go in those room and
there's an item I can't get it right I
would recommend going just to an item
box
I need nighttime right I'm telling you
there's two ways to get to this one I
would recommend going through the first
floor so I could show you the shortcut
you opened up so go through like just
like as a recommendation I would say
stay on this floor go through that way
and try those locked doors sure cuz if
one of them is a sword a sword or you'll
discard the and I just saved so if I die
I die I'm not
if he dies he dies you know that movie I
need more than if he dies he say it
again in that boy make you sorry I'm
like stressed out already was there's
AAM's in here this is the where you saw
that first ever zombie that Barry killed
that was eating Kenneth's right does he
back to life or nobody didn't need to
burn that guy - don't you the burn no
hehe was he walked into the dining room
and Barry killed him his magnum like a
headshot right gotcha I think that's you
breathing yeah it's you okay sorry
mouth breather I'm trying to guide you
through this and you're insulting me oh
all right fine I like you I just
you're also breathe heavily through your
mouth oh that's a dead guy okay got it
earning buddies on a Tuesday
actually it's Wednesday yeah it's what
Saturday when we publish this right
that's right it's Wednesday right now
we're specifically wait he's he's gone
he just they don't disappear until he
leaved area he's just charred right now
Oh hurry it's misleading barbecue yeah I
was actually gonna say while I'm here
cuz I forgot to in the last episode if
you guys like what you see here and you
guys enjoy this type of Steve please
like and subscribe the video it helps us
do more strange things like this that we
don't get to normally do also if you're
like I like this but I wish it was I
wish I could have it on a Friday or
whatever you can let us know in the
comments
it helps armor okay it helps us to know
when to publish these things cuz we
don't really do a lot of long-form
content content so it's it's always like
a risk so so very early in the game now
that you're done shilling our content
very early in the game sorry
somebody has to yeah now that you're
done early in the game you went down
this hallway and did not like what you
saw cuz it's the basement yes and I
didn't go down or it did but I don't
want to go to the basement we want to
stay on this floor and go to that
typewriter well okay
keep in mind you want to try as many
doors as possible to get rid of sake if
you can it doesn't mean you have to go
there just because you can unlock the
door and not go through it right Oh
I'm freaking out okay
how do I know when the sword key boom
diggity now you got an empty slot and
don't I swear about that key anymore so
I can discard it yeah and you don't have
to go through there
it's up to you whether you want to I'm
just saying like that's my point you can
unlock doors without actually entering
the room I understand uh I would like to
well I haven't I have a free spot now so
see mm-hm so I don't mind going through
it okay basements are always a good
place to be horror games oh my god don't
now you're making zombie noises you can
creep yourself out I know I'm not a
zombie how can you be so sure oh my god
I'll get that HG magazine piece of meat
raccoon meat you have a like five
defensive item here a really good shape
of that can you uh can you be maxed out
on defensive items I don't even know I
don't think I've ever had that many you
bet your sweet buns I'll take that
magazine I wonder if there's anything
else I'm missing in here I don't want to
check out that meat anymore but I don't
want to miss anything so I'm gonna keep
looking either I'm not a good cook look
I got some messed up spices it's like
oregano
yeah I'm gonna say it's like just
cilantro is it what what is this for Oh
spice these monsters using basil of our
parsley I keep mine you can check your
map and I'll tell you like 100 percent
or in progress or 100 percent right
right right that's smart well it's it's
blinking green I think that means I'm
done all right so I just tried this door
that looks like an oven and it didn't
work
there's also another red door in this
creepy little hallway to the back with a
creepy hallway
yikes all right let's do it
Oh Lord here we go oh okay I have a
thing okay oh wait I thought oh I wanted
you to watch it
can I get hurt yes a little bit um cool
it's an elevator which is the power
doesn't seem to be turned on after
watching the zombie burn I'm turned on
anyway that's the basement so no das
cutscene why what's happening no no no
don't fall like Turney or two when she's
back then [ __ ] her name is Becca I
thought I would actually encourage you
to use a defensive item right here you
have a lot but I don't like it how do i
how do I use it
never mind just shoot him no how do I
use it just I mean you go up to him and
have him grab you just do not let him
grab you from behind otherwise you can I
see it so I want him to grab me but I
can't grab my back right and I just just
stand and let me know I'll use it I I
mean you could shoot him still like I
would you have fun you have a good
amount of I use it yep so it's like that
won't kill him but um I would let you
let him get up I wouldn't or you can
shoot down were dead him if you want
wait I would let him come at you oh wait
you've got should save you a few rounds
ah you know what if you had gotten a
headshot by chance you would have been
able to get the dagger back up stay down
you know it fuel here I know I should
have told you to walk up and let it
occur curb something not you're fine you
still only use it three rounds as
opposed to like potential yeah I don't
have any I don't have any [ __ ] fuel
yeah that's fine what if he becomes a
redhead he might but at least you get
Radek added the other one ones better
than two
all right so sorry let me do this thing
that I have gotten really used to doing
so sore keys gone which is good okay
there's a beer [ __ ] be you know you
use leave unlocks all the doors you can
at this point so now you need I need to
get her or the helmet so I'm getting out
of the basement I need an armored helmet
key I need to turn on the power to the
elevator oh and I need our original task
was to get excuse me there we go to get
to that item box isn't to get rid of
some stuff that I don't need right now
because I have too much stuff mm-hmm
also I don't know if you remember one of
your overarching objectives right now
you remember the four masks they
mentioned yes yeah you're also kind of
looking for those but you'll come across
those I feel like I'll worry about that
more when I get there
mm-hmm sorry I'm still I still don't
understand this area very well so I'm
gonna go all the way to get its hallway
yeah that's where you first saw that
zombie he was eating Kenneth great of
course Kenneth yeah of course
the zombies name was Barbie
open windows creep me on this game do I
need to burn him to eventually anytime
I'm not talking it's weird they just
don't shut up oh my god not the cross oh
right
that window Bonnie's creeping me out
shut up [ __ ] hate those crows should
I use a plant mhm what your inventory
looking like oh it's I got one slot yeah
take it with you cuz like I'm on well
you don't have to use it you could just
still bring it back to your I would just
take it and if you don't get hit just
keep it in your safe box for potential
like red herb dummy I mean if I don't
get hit
I'm saying ideally you won't get hit so
then you could just instead of using
that so when you go out you you've been
through here keep in mind so I'm going
up the stairs
mmm-hmm and I don't have to figure it
out like he remember past then shut up
shut up I sound awful hate crows good
[ __ ] I can't burn any of these buds okay
but remember out something you won't
like that shortcut last episode where as
previously the two doors down this
hallway we're broken okay so let me let
me try to if you go all the way down
that hallway if I take a right see the
dining room at the bottom left of the
map mmm yeah see those two blue doors
the north end of the dining remember you
you originally went out that one and
then back in the other to get to the
safe room you unlock that shortcut this
time so you're literally right next to
the door that leads to the hallway with
a safe room right now if I go in here
yes that's that one you unlock last
night so all I just need to do is take a
right through this hallway mm-hmm
hope hope those bodies don't reanimate
Jesus and if they do just so remember
this is this is a pretty good shortcut
actually you don't have to it's it's not
super useful you just get to avoid the
upper floor of the balcony dining room
sorry what and then so like go down to
the first floor map see the safe rooms
like pretty much under you right now
right but I still gotta get there so
I'll have to do is take these stairs
down mm-hm this is the medical safe room
isn't there a zombunny here
you burn one of them you burned a couple
of them you're also near that room with
more kerosene there no no this is a safe
room there's never a zombie in a safe
room but there was a zombie right
outside this room oh yeah that yeah I
thought I burned that [ __ ]
and we leave this up to you what you
leave me take
I feel like I need everything else don't
you think okay so what would you say is
the next like what what's the if you
could get one item right now to help you
in the game would it be the armored key
okay do you remember reading oh the dog
whistle there you go nice okay and you
know like assuming it is a feral dog the
shotguns gonna be useful to have right
pistol doesn't knock them back and
damage them I'd like to be fully healed
before I take on any more did you put
the ink ribbons back yes okay do you
think I need them should I save no no
I'm just trying to think where is where
they said the dog was yeah it was in the
second oh my god hold on I'm sorry I
have anxiety I'd like to get more
kerosene yeah dude yeah that rooms right
here down to the hallway is it to the
right mm-hmm the adjacent room at the
save room there's windows always
creeping up I hate windows after that
dog jumped through there I'll never
forget that well the dog biting me in
the butt though that was like
exceptionally upsetting okay give me
that car singing so honestly I know this
is like not the most interesting but
what I'd like to do is I'd like to
refill my canteen burn that zombie
that's right outside of the safe room
come back and get more kerosene and then
burn those bodies that are in the thing
that are right next to me I'd like to
burn everybody that's near me oh yeah
that makes sense gonna conserve ammo
down the road is there is the
possibility that they could already turn
into crimson heads but no no you're
accepting that risk when you burn them
right now so that's just what the game
is
I have no problem your philosophy right
now
don't be crimson sorry I like this
genuinely creepier than anything
happening again when I make those noises
alright so he won't be there when I come
back
oh wait correct him so there's two sorry
excuse me I know this is like not the
most interesting thing to watch but I
think this is important no sleep so I'm
going to man I'm going to go back refill
my canteen
there's two zoms right where I was I'm
gonna I'm gonna burn them now and I'm
gonna even go back and get kerosene as a
third time just because I'd rather have
it and yeah make sounds like there's no
reason there's no reason not to mm-hmm I
like the way you're thinking because you
don't want to fight crimson heads if
they're stronger like they take more
bullets they take more bullets they will
be more aggressive and they're faster
they're like they're like World War Z
zombies as opposed to Night of the
Living Dead zombies that make sense wait
which door was it is this one right mhm
you'll be standing on him when you go
through oh god I hope he's not a crimson
head no no no no no no come on give me a
break
come on
and then there's one here did you know
that was gonna happen
yeah yeah I need you to do but yeah it's
good you escaped
just remember he's there waiting to eat
your face so do you remember what's up
those stairs like where he just was that
the other door remember that's where
that first that's where you put the
replica key in place of the sore key
that would have killed you with those
statues if you didn't right right I'm
going down okay
god this place is so confusing alright
so now I gotta get more kerosene Josh
I'm curious didn't use your not okay I
checked that was like my first Mike the
first thing I thought of was a [ __ ]
better no wasted kerosene because that's
horseshit use a little bit of tiny bit
of the Zippo fuel though I have Zippo
fuel well on your later I don't know if
it's as if oh I doubt it
suppose were really popular because they
that brand gave a bunch of lighters to
the army so like a bunch of army people
had suppose and then that became like
the standard light her to have during
like World War two yeah I was like
really smart it's like probably like the
best marketing thing they ever did also
it was just really nice of them
was it World War two the M&M started
World War one is they literally to ship
them they needed a shell around it so
they wouldn't melt chocolate too well I
think that sounds been around a while it
sounds like a to thing cuz world will
one you're trying old school M&Ms
although M&Ms are pretty old we'd have
to look it up mmm-hmm all right should I
take care of that redhead or should I do
it later no don't worry about him I'll
tell you that you would want shotgun
rounds to take care of him
oh really he's that tough it's not that
their toughest you need
knock back so they did I mean you have a
lot of defensive items you could you
will be back there so don't worry about
it right now
all right well I guess to be honest with
you I'm not really sure where to go then
because oh oh the dog whistle Maxine
remember where they said the tab area
second floor east
that's my wait actually is there awake
come on go back to my eye oh yeah your
inventory go to files okay and then you
can reread man oh right good call good
call
crumbled memo maybe I think that's hmm
there you go second floor balcony on the
west side of the terrace okay so I am on
the second floor and I need to go the
west side balcony is that talking about
this
no that's the crow room okay where's the
west side balcony cuz I'm on the second
floor
mm-hmm so it's like right here is it
this room no no it's it's the perimeter
of the mansion so boom there you go yeah
that door to the common like
circumference of the UH
now listen readjust it's the lock pick
door that I don't know if you unlike yet
but it's a lock pick door to get out
okay it's that like garden door
I would like to refill my health to max
and I would like to equip my shotgun
does that seem reasonable mm-hmm what's
your health Aaron no it's that caution
yeah do you want I'm just thinking ahead
good yeah in good shape
Oh oh there's two of them no don't don't
know [ __ ] okay you got a defensive item
use a defensive item use it if I would
okay
do not use shotgun shells right now
let's think about this why because okay
here's what I want you to do I just so
you know I was totally going to and I
hit the wrong button and opened my map
instead of shooting him it's alright
which is good he's naive okay so I mean
I'm defensive I don't I just don't let
him grab you from behind when you use
the defensive item then you have 6 X or
shotgun shells in your city I would
encourage you to try to use the pistol
once he's down it's not guaranteed to
knock him down but you have enough
defensive items that so I need to
re-equip once I use this defensive item
or just decide my shotgun though they
both reanimated yeah so that you
wouldn't be able to burn him anyway they
would have done that um see that's why I
didn't want to use the green herb
there's some right here that you can use
your final you're good Yoli good when
you go back through there later you'll
want my shotgun equipped or not
yeah nice wing right mhm yeah the West
Terrace whatever sorry I'm just thinking
out loud so am i all right I don't want
these yet right you can't use them you
don't pick them up this just refilled
your health they're like it's a garden
not necessarily one green herb I didn't
know that I know I don't want to just
tell you that was coming though you're
fine you're really you're good there are
enough herbs lying around there's
permanent there's permanent there's only
okay there's only enough for a few uses
no cuz I don't need it correct
they let you eat herbs when you're at
full health this game is mean well yeah
sometimes that's a strategy to get rid
of items slots alright let me collect my
bearings here I need to use this dog
whistle mm-hmm should I use it here
I use it by the door so I can jump get
out if you know you're gonna be fighting
a dog I would try to find a more open
area to maneuver could there already be
dogs in here it could be but I'm just
saying either way I don't I wouldn't
wanna fight a dog in this what angle was
that actually I guess you want to like
enclosed no yeah you'll just keep series
pretty big have I been here before no so
do you see that door at the end yep
where that's gonna go you're going back
to the state so you know when you go
through that door you'll be safe
theoretically is law months they put
like zombies in the main hall but I need
a key to get in there which the dog has
no no that's one of the doors I was
locked from the other side and now
you're on the other side should I just
open it now I should just get the key
yeah all right
[ __ ] dog
so what from my perspective when I'm
fighting a dog I want the camera angle
to be wide enough that by the time I
even see him near me I can like aim and
kill him so like this area seems nice
mm-hmm because I could like dodge and
aim and kill him mm-hmm
that sound right mm-hmm okay all right
all right I'm gonna use it I feel good
you feel good
mm-hmm okay here we go feel good
Oh oh no I got me I was trying to shoot
him he was faster than me master go try
get a calorie should I burn the ball the
dogs dogs don't come back - yeah you're
fine there's no crimson dog no [ __ ] am I
in German one no actually I mean you
killed both them I would just recommend
going to use that Carina that green
plant the permanent plant
perm plant mm-hmm they cannot reanimate
correct even if they could you have to
leave if there were regular zombies they
were bleeding you have to leave and then
come back for them to do so okay oh
those moths I'm waiting for trip dog
Cerberus just three dogs Cerberus is
like a whole nother setting there's
three dog oh he's from fallout 3 the
radio host enough pop-culture references
I don't know if you'd call Greek
mythology pop culture but yeah you're
good wouldn't you're back in the green
yo G up that's what I call it using
herbs GN up hey I'm trying to guide you
through I'm gonna recommend some lingo -
it's I didn't say anything I didn't come
up with it just observe you consciously
like a comma so that's what they call
using green herbs jian up all right I
don't think that that's official
most most slang isn't I I don't think
anybody's ever what it's asking to
discard the dog whistle you don't need
it anymore
now you free up a slot suite so yeah
okay cool great so I just have a caller
am I supposed to do with that no you can
examine items also also earlier in this
episode I said that you have already
done something that you have not you're
about to oh can i I just wanna see
something real fast is it can I just see
what the emblem is could it be by that
door the one that said the Spencer yes
the lion tour yes is that a lion no
should I just press it and see what
happens
yeah put the collar on and then press it
to see what happens I just I'm kidding
just severs your head I don't I save no
just I'm telling you press it
Oh Marcy so do you see what it's called
the armored key no no yeah read that oh
I can zoom in
lacks the rigid II don't I got this
so this harkens back to the first
episode we recorded
relax the rigid II what the [ __ ]
rigidity I don't know what that means
just like stiffness it's not key enough
yeah but it's an imitation of a key okay
I don't know if you'd like so we
recorded the first episode a week ago
can I replace a key with it like should
I be replacing the key from the other
key you're on the right track
okay I mean I can use the fertilizer on
the key and grow a key yeah do that I
think you know what you're doing I just
think you forgot where it was
remember I said like have you seen
Raiders of the Lost Ark when he replaces
the thing with the thing yes the weight
you might not remember where this was
though there was this long string of
suits of armor hallway and that was the
one where like it was on the first floor
it was in this this area it was in this
area yes on the west side it was fairly
early on like very early on okay so I
want to go downstairs mmm I want to save
well if you want to save then the
quickest way the safe room is through
these doors and then around the balcony
of the dining room and then through that
obviously say go downstairs
Oh to the typewriter in the diner you
don't have any Griffins though oh you're
right
that's why you're here so I want to go
backwards
yeah oh my god the crimson head yeah
there are two crimson heads in your way
I have two shotgun shells and you've got
defensive items I would encourage you to
try not to use a shotgun shells but you
got defensive items I can't take out
crimson heads with defensive items it's
not gonna kill them but it'll help
I could I mean theoretically it could if
I have to kill them or I'm wasting my
time remember right if I don't kill them
no go to your defensive items actually
switched to the stun gun because that
does more damage I only have one though
yeah no it'll automatically go to the
daggers if you use the stun guns did I
pick it no there you go okay so you do
have six extra shotgun shells so I'm
going through this main blue door here
yes hmm
so right behind me and there's two
Crimson's in there mm-hmm and I'm gonna
kill them actually
yeah go through there so here's what you
hear here two options to get back to the
safe room you're gonna have to go past
two crimson heads to get down the stairs
to the safe room
or you could use that shortcut you
unlocked to just you could the door to
the right on the upper balcony go go
into the dining room and then I'll
explain it remember that zombies up here
there's two zombies in there up in this
room there's that one that you don't
have to kill at all
it's around the circular just going I'm
uncomfortable I'm confused the layout of
the rooms I remember this one oh my god
I'm turning into a zombie
don't alright so I wouldn't walk this
way I would circle the balcony first why
he's not there you're going to be he's
there so which door am I trying to get
to the left one I can't do either so um
I will tell you if you go through the
right one that's toward the key the
armor key but if you go through the left
I want to save so the two crimson heads
are pretty much right on the other side
of that left door that's also where you
the dory Rainier the door used to get on
the West Terrace so I need to go through
those crimson heads to save if you go
through the right throw there can be a
crimson head as well because that's the
one that you like walked on each other
so both require horseshit you know I
probably want to do the left one and
take out the two crimson head so I can
get to the safe I would try to avoid
them if possible it's gonna be tough but
yeah yeah
you want me to avoid them now when I do
that I go down stairs right here here's
my thing if you avoid them go down
stairs and save you're gonna have to
encounter them again when because you're
gonna have to come back up right the key
that you're trying to get is up here so
my suggestion would be to to not do that
what but then if I die I have to redo
all this you're gonna have to go through
them no matter what to get to the safe
room
I would okay here's here's my thing okay
no I've got it I've got it I've got it
you're not gonna save for a little bit
okay well guide you through it though go
through the right door you're gonna have
to encounter one crimson head okay this
way you want me to use one of my items
if partly to avoid him or yeah use
defensive item and then your
don't waste any shock and then where am
I going once I get in that room the left
stairs are the rights to right stairs
you'll recognize where you are once you
get there it's just okay come this way
stupid where is he where is he he's good
so he's not in urine
he might be knee right but you can get
through yeah there you go okay so
there's a crimson in here on the toward
the end the hallway okay that's where
you got the arrow head a lot of these
places have only been once it's like
really come this is a hallway mhm
you'll recognize it and there's a
crimson in here [ __ ] some taking a left
down this hallway and then taking a
right and then another right and I got a
kill a crimson head mm-hmm you don't
have to kill him but you could eat
Hewitt he might be easier to avoid them
oh my god
that's him yeah I would say use your
pistol on a defensive item you should be
good
yeah bait him down this hallways he can
get a few shots in he's fast though so
good be fun can you see me I don't know
I love that shot though sorry we
shouldn't be paying attention to this
shot composition right now he's not
coming you could theoretically dodge him
I would say just saying no I would say
go for the dodge anyway cuz worst case
scenario he grabs you as long as it's
not from behind use defensively right I
understand you're saying cuz all I have
to do is jump into this hallway real
quick and take a right go down those
stairs yeah might here's my thing though
if you do use a defense I have many
Falls don't waste that shoot him a few
times on the ground I understand did I
do it he hit me I'm gonna shoot him wait
I'd get on yeah there you go sweet okay
killed him that's why the stun gun was
good you did get hit but you're probably
the yellow how do I get hit though just
he didn't grab you he swung they'd
sometimes do that I just didn't yeah it
didn't really you're good
you're still fine it didn't hurt you it
at all that's weird lucky for you oh I
need to burn while you use it no no
crimson heads don't reanimate that's the
last the final form okay so he will
disappear when you go back through cool
that worked out way better I thought
that was why the stun gun was better
than the daggers should I take this
plant
what's your inventory looking like I got
two spaces yeah you might as well try to
start hoarding those in your safe box if
you're gonna go to saver Memphis how
just take both of them I oh no no no no
sorry don't you can't you need to uh
take one for now why I'm going to a safe
room you'll be coming back but just
remember remember what you're doing with
the key you need to be able to pick up
something what before you replace I
thought I was gonna go to the safe room
before that happens is that not the case
no I'm telling you you'll be fine you'll
recognize this room I might the armor
key opens a lot of the imagine a load
that like Goku noise you make
just checking the layout it appears
there's stairs in front of you cobwebs
okay you remember this
yes mm-hmm so it looks like I could
replace that key with a key boom diggity
this is when I brought up Raiders of the
Lost Ark should I run should I get prep
to run no no I mean no you don't need to
if you're replacing it
I bet if I okay should I take it and
then immediately use the other one
mm-hmm there's no like option to live
replace no no no you'll be fine
I know what your concern is that's that
was mine when I first did it too but
you'll be able to place it it gives you
time to react like more than enough time
Oh oh my god make sure you put the right
one there you go oh I love the little
like shards of floor or wall the plaster
that came off so it kind of hints that
those are gonna come in if you're paying
attention I guess what you never would
have been able to do that in the first
plate ps1 oh my head that's so stressful
I got a key come on examine it okay
armor key there's that rigidity you were
looking for the rigid II I lost my
rigidity my rigid e to a key in the
Attic all right
I I would like to save I've done a lot
of good stuff um can I use should I just
go down that red door so you have two
options you can either go the long route
I love options you can either fight to
crimson heads which would the shotgun
ammo you have right now I would not
recommend uh-huh or you could go the
long way to the other save room in the
East Wing and go to save there which
that's I would recommend that because
you don't have a ton of shotgun ammo and
whatnot uh-huh
so what about this red door down here
you could try it out I'd save you time
it's not a armored door so so now you're
pretty much is opening armored doors
which if you don't remember where they
are that's fine just trial and error
great I don't remember I don't there's
always that like one or two okay before
I even do that I would like I
like - yeah for not saying I would
highly recommend going to the East one
because there are two crimson heads
circling the corridor above and you
don't have a shortcut right now that
what you can get to the lower West
save room without what's the quickest
way to get to the east then just
backtrack to the dining room balcony and
then main hall and then to the upper
floors right cuz keep my their dogs
prowling the East first floor which you
can avoid now you just have to go
through the second floor it's gonna take
longer but it's worth it you're in the
long run you'll save way more ammo and
I'll be alone you know you have more
chance of surviving yeah it's just it's
gonna take a little bit longer yeah this
is a good time for me to remember where
the [ __ ] I am alright so I want to go am
I going to the first floor or do I want
to go to a second okay so I'm gonna take
a left here and go down to this open
area with the zombie that I can dodge
really easily mm-hmm I would bet you can
and then go into the main area and go
downstairs yeah and you could bring a
couple herbs with you right now -
they're sitting there not one order we
stock up on them okay I understand I
understand why you wouldn't let me take
two Arabs ill you would have died not
you wouldn't no you wouldn't have even
been able to pick up the key and I
understand okay so I'm going down this
hall mhm you were getting far too come
on I couldn't have that oh mercy all
right going straight prepare to dodge
zombie
sorry no matter how many times I do this
I keep getting confused I think this
one's an Armour but I'm not gonna go in
it yet because I want to save try it out
remember if it is an armored door
alright so you had that you letter you
have to be on their side I'm like that
one got it god I got it alright so
there's a zombie close we're yet we're
yet we're yet oh that's right old you
got left
I did call office Oh dose so I want to
go here man this is a puzzler mm-hmm
it's way more of a puzzle game than I
thought yeah there's a lot of
forethought involved with the early
resonable games earlier okay some going
down no no I would say the first floor
has a dog on it that you could avoid a
first and second right and would have
had two dogs you hadn't killed that
other one on the terrace with the
herbicide that you got okay so I'm going
through this story yeah you're you're
aiming for those stairs on the north
side are there any dogs in here not on
the second floor now on the first floor
yeah but that's why I'm telling you stay
in the second great so I'm going through
this hallway I'm gonna take a right at
the end of the hallway mm-hmm through
that green door mm-hmm and I'm gonna go
through that other blue door and go down
the stairs yes okay I just like game
plans cuz it makes me feel better
mm-hmm I feel way more comfortable
knowing
extra fun no just no I have a game plan
we decided I'm gonna save you time we
decided on game plan okay okay okay
know what no we have time we've got
we've got what time are you gonna say me
I would say use this go through the
store right now wait let me see your
inventory actually I'm full nevermind I
can't okay
now run at least unlock this door okay
there you go you know to go through it
though it's that last one mm-hmm I
wonder when those crows are gonna come
into play I feel like you don't have
loud [ __ ] I'm sorry I wasn't alas this
works to just go through the other side
of this room do you know what I mean
though you like you don't have loud
crows unless they're gonna kill you at
some point maybe the developers realize
that it's unsettling and put them in
there for no reason at all maybe they
realize that just having a narrative to
why the crows are there isn't settling
or is settling and comforting
maybe they realize that making sense of
things is the only way we know I don't
believe okay what am i doing I went down
these stairs just like we discussed hmm
and you're there pretty much oh and I
just go to this blue door right here
mm-hmm
yeah so to the right to the top the
Blanc the bottom is the one that you use
twice wait Joey read that was that new
love he's a redhead no we don't like
redheads
all right watch your first day it
spreads some incendiary reasons for your
grenade launcher which you don't have
yet what a nice guy
alright I'm just gonna really it's weird
cuz I come combine other things yeah but
you can combine two green herbs to make
something different and I don't think
they want to do that in the actual box
yeah I would recommend putting those in
the say box so they will be in any other
safe room you go to have we talked about
that how if you put something to a say
box it's in all the same box in the game
I made that assumption based on my
history of playing video games okay but
there is some trouble either no it's
[ __ ] stupid it's game yeah cuz I can
do it with these with handgun ammo yeah
but but you can't like I don't know
first-aid sprays are way bigger than
bullets
yeah but magazines not really logic
should I keep us
I would espresso with me jump two slots
right now get rid of increments for now
just put those in the box and then go
safe it's annoying I realized that but
what dump the ink ribbons right now I
can't save without I know but those in
the box
pick up the incendiary grenades and the
first days spray put those back in the
box just so you have them in the box not
to worry about anymore
okay I understand then save I understand
okay I go we mean it's just so you don't
have to yeah yeah I got it that way if I
die I don't have to do this again
correct
I understand
so tell me this did incendiary shells if
I kill the zombie with them do they
already they're already on fire which
means I won't get a crimson head
theoretically I would save the shells
for bigger enemies than just a zombies
though there's bigger enemies and
zombies yes it wasn't like a dismissive
laugh it felt dismissive rookie no yeah
it's not just taking presence oh there
are there are numerous kinds of enemies
making good progress saving is the only
thing that makes me happy
mmm-hmm you do know you can only save
eight times in this game and you're at
six right now and you have another like
four hours
you can't override saves in this game
yes you can they can that was kidding
the part if you believe me no I didn't
know part of you looking like my fuel oh
I have to
all right so with the time we have left
for this episode I I would say that door
you unlocked on the second floor let's
go through it yeah go through that I
mean I have like a [ __ ] hand I would
pick that up just so you have it when
you went next time you save you can
bring it back I have a headache from
like [ __ ] we should probably shouldn't
even saved just now you have an
increment just cuz we're gonna say it
again in ten minutes you have enough
increments that you're good there's you
probably finish the game
like with six extra increments or so
this way right yeah that's the way you
came through right isn't that what we're
doing because we're going through this
door mm-hmm so I could also go through
here is what you're saying that's faster
yeah okay let's do that and you also
can't go through that door to your right
it's like locked from the other side I
just don't want you to do that thing
where you're like you can only go
through that door one no I don't like
prompt you and say this door now is
falling apart puzzles Oh oh my god oh
okay woe to those who disturb my sleep
press button to disturb there's a sweet
I think I just like to look around real
fast
before I press buttons I can move these
okay I can move them but we're all right
this kind of seems like the kind of okay
so this guy's can I move him oh he
didn't like that did not like did not
care for that all right I'm learning
don't don't give anything away can I
move them this can I move him this way
okay can I pull them one would think I
don't think this game allows you to
though this is an ocarina of time oh but
that one didn't move backwards I find
that really interesting this one moved
and this one didn't do this stuff on the
wall of anything to do with it I haven't
put it together yet but I'm gonna
continue to move them backwards and see
what happens
okay okay how about this one I don't
think you push them all the way oh okay
I can only have one backwards no no all
three of them are backwards I'm just
kidding there's an order that I need to
do this is that what's happening try
that it I'm just speaking out loud yeah
there is sir I would like to I'd like
I'd rather die
alright so shield uh axe sword pike
great I will say that of all the times I
play the game I've never taken the time
to actually figure out what they're
trying to tell me I just do trial and
error do you know what the objective is
right now my objective might not be the
game's objective but my objective is to
get them all backwards which I would
consider their sleep state and certain
pushing certain ones is like reversed as
moving certain ones that's right so
ideally you would want to have like say
the shield this isn't the case but say
the shield knight will always move the
sword knight to the opposite side you
would want the shield - or die out so
when you push this ya leave the room
yeah I don't press that until you figure
well I didn't want to listen to you
anyway
okay fine figure yourself oh no I'm
almost dead yeah too bad I hope he died
laughs when he died should I use a herb
probably or just mmm just figure out the
puzzle without dying mm-hmm we find out
the gas was still pumping in all right
so I'm almost dead here we go
shield axe sword pike thing I'm not sure
if those are the actual names of the
weapons I'm doing my best here wait wait
what the pushing the shield night did it
made that guy go backwards mm-hmm
cuz leak I honestly have never figured
out what they're trying to tell me with
these I just do trial and error they're
like I try to figure out what yeah I
really don't think the wall is telling
you much and if it is I don't think it's
not useful [ __ ] I'm going around in
circles
try the other guy yeah okay somewhere
the shield won't do anything so I want
to do that work laughs no the shield one
makes that guy go oh wait so maybe you
were yeah
no this guy makes this guy go there yeah
you're right
shield made that guy well let's hope
hope this goes up this goes well I'd be
funny if you just wanted them to be out
sick you guys are dumb did it I would
like to examine the body examine that
cheese oh my god I just want to take a
good look at it um okay well go back to
the top
these are all switches I'll go back to
the top of the box and sunshine will
open it right okay
sunshine is two halves of a heart and
the moon are two rectangle things so I
want I want to open these did I do it
yeah oh [ __ ] oh that's one of the four
mm-hmm cool ooh just remaining progress
on that front - what do you mean there's
nothing unusual [ __ ] is that a death
mask there's nothing unusual about it my
mom got me one for my birthday
mm-hmm she came to my bedroom in the
morning wearing one for a mask it
doesn't have I hold a head up it was a
mask up my brother's face oh my god
turns out it was my brother's face he's
dead well he's alive he just doesn't
have a faith so is it really him I don't
might be a good place to save and call
it I'm almost dead should I use some
health no you can get back to the same
room without any encounters hope you can
you're pretty close to a save him right
now yeah I'm very close
so foreboding seeing those doors downs
the style was loud thunder thunder
scares me in real life - should I heal
before I save that way I'm healed next
time we start I'm not gonna start yeah
we're gonna heal that use a first-aid
spray it not why because you could save
that green herb later for a row for a
red herb I understand
death mask I would recommend not
carrying right now there's need for
later on
oh I can't put it in now you could I
mean just right if you want to save it
on the episode I would say just man this
is exciting I have yeah I mean instead
of taking all four masks later on to go
do that it would be nice to periodically
I forgots good right I understand we
were saying I thought maybe it would
give me something if I put one mask in
oh I see what you're saying
it was pretty good got a lot
accomplished I used to listen to this
song to fall asleep I was young this and
what's that world in Super Mario 64 the
lagoon oh yeah you're talking about I
don't know yeah for the one with with
the eel in the ship yes we use listens
on a car ride sometimes cool well you
say it's called like Crystal Lake or
something I don't remember
good cool well I guess that's a place to
call it call me three all right you
making good progress
I think that's episode three yeah sweet
join us for the conclusion of Resident
Evil is that any way of keeping people
hooked just why I just don't know when
how long the game is so I genuinely
assume that every episode could be the
conclusion you could beat it in like ten
minutes
really is there a secret no you don't
know thank you guys for watching again
don't forget to Like and subscribe these
videos we can make more of them also put
in the comments what you guys like what
you want to see more of if you guys want
to suppose these at a different time
that always helps because we are winging
it I will be back again next week with
Mike McCarty playing more Resident Evil
thanks for watching